it's challenging to go to the UN and
participate in the system where the UN
says you know we have this formula and
every country gets to have a certain
amount of people get jobs at the UN so
they look at the formula and they say oh
well how many people do we have from
Nigeria oh we need more go hire people
into the system from Nigeria it tends to
not be whether or not someone is
qualified more has the skill set it is
are we being fair and equal on the
disbursement of jobs out of this idea
lately right and that's where it breaks
down because you're hiring people that
really don't know what they're doing and
they waste money and the UN becomes a
jobs program if you talk a little bit
about just generally what the state of
the UN is and what it was like to be
there and you know that so many people
think that it's like this sort of
perfect thing that the countries come
together and figure out what's right for
everybody like they love the idea of it
more than I think functionally how it
works right or does not work well first
of all the I always try to correct
people that the UN doesn't really exist
the UN as member states right so when
somebody says oh the UN says no I always
said the UN doesn't say no members at
the UN maybe Russia and China got
together in the Security Council and
said no but the UN doesn't take a
position and so I try to not just
reflexively blame oh the UN and stop
something because it's really member
countries that's the first thing the
second thing is is the UN does not work
unless the US is leading it whether it's
the World Food Program UNICEF UNDP you
know the development programs whatever
it is the US has to be there otherwise
the UN does not work the UN system is
based on every country is equal not
every person is equal it's every country
and that's where I think as Americans we
say that's just fundamentally not true
every country is not equal so in the
General Assembly when we pretend that
these small island countries get the
same vote as China or the United States
or
you know the bigger economies that's
kind of laughable to be honest I get
that we want to have a general assembly
where people have the ability to talk
but I don't love the idea of one country
one vote which i think is balanced by
the Security Council in the and the idea
that the substantive work goes to the
Security Council so I get the kind of
separation but it's challenging to go to
the UN and participate in the system
where the UN says you know we have this
formula and every country gets to have a
certain amount of people get jobs at the
UN so they look at the formula and they
say oh well how many people do we have
from Nigeria oh we need more go hire
people into the system from Nigeria it
tends to not be whether or not someone
is qualified more has the skill set it
is are we being fair and equal on the
disbursement of jobs out of this I do
right and that's where it breaks down
because you're hiring people that really
don't know what they're doing and they
waste money and the UN becomes a jobs
program is that you had better at
certain things and worse at others so
like when it comes to food disbursement
in our helping development that kind of
stuff it seems like they're probably
pretty decent at and then the Security
Council or a lot of the rest of it seems
like 90% of it is just voting against
the Israel
yeah you know yeah for sure moving Iraq
yeah I think you hit it on the head is
that you know we pay 25 percent of the
UN bill and that's for the Secretariat
and the kind of UN administration and
all the parking tickets right isn't the
whole thing just parking tickets no it's
just
ambassadors you get to park wherever you
want yeah but at the same time there are
these what they call extra bodies
independent bodies and those are funded
through voluntary contributions so World
Food Program in UNICEF they don't get
monies from the the general fund of the
25 percent money that we give UNICEF
only gets its budget by appealing to
people say to say we've got a crisis we
need to go out and who wants to write us
a check the Europe
the Germans the Americans we fund the
most on those World Food Program UNICEF
type independent bodies that's why
they're the well run isn't because we
demand management transparency and an
accountability in these independent
bodies we don't have that ability to do
in the UN General Assembly so the you
get this kind of really blob type
management and and mission from the
actual UN operations what is the
obsession with Israel with the General
Assembly I mean every every time you
look at that chart it's like nine
percent of the condom nation's well you
know that there's only one country that
can't serve on the Security Council
that's Israel I'm outraged by it I'm
telling you I think that the US
government should just put its foot down
and say we're gonna clear the deck and
Israel should be on the Security Council
just to prove a point of getting them on
the cap on the Security Council it
there's this fascination with condemning
Israel it's why we got out of the Human
Rights Council is because you know
you've got nine resolutions on Israel
and nothing on you know Iran or or I
mean the word is out if you if you don't
want to be condemned by the UN and
you're a human rights abuser then go run
the Human Rights Council attacked
yourself right Trump somehow just gets
all this like he really has fixed a lot
of this or is in the process of fixing
adores you know he's not of the
political establishment and so he's
willing to be a disruptor we all know
about disruptive technology and people
who go in and say gosh everybody has a
groupthink and you're missing the big
you know reform effort I think Americans
really want Washington to be disrupted
or the UN they look at it and they say
what a waste you know why are we
spending all that money but the system
in Washington filled with lobbyists and
and all the people that take care of
each other they don't want an outsider
coming in and somehow wrecking their
good fortune you know and and we see
that in Hollywood we see that same thing
in Hollywood and so I want to to applaud
and do everything I can for president
Trump because first of all he's got
really thick skin all of the people who
just constantly come at him for thank
God we got a president who's just really
tough on that and doesn't care and two
he sees it for what it is and he's not
really that partisan I mean I look at
what I'm starting to to call the Trump
doctrine which I think the Trump
doctrine to foreign policy which is a
dual approach to every single issue
where you use every tool of the US
government economic tool sanctions
pressure to change the behavior of a
country and you really utilize that
pressure in a strong way at the same
time there's this separate path to say
let's talk let's sit down and have a
diplomatic talk he's doing it with Kim
Jong moon and the the neo cons and the
traditional Republicans did not like him
saying I'm gonna go just go talk to Kim
Jong moon they only want to do the
squeezing mm-hmm they don't always want
to say well why not talk to see if we
can test this talking is a tactic it's
not it's not the goal so when I see that
when you see then like the never Trump
conservatives so like the bill crystals
or just those guys that have sort of
been around forever and who usually
you've gotten everything wrong always
are they different privately like are
they privately kind of like yeah I like
what he's doing and he's I don't think
so I think the creatures of Washington I
think they live in Washington DC and
they they they want people to play by
the rules the people who benefit from
the rules and and they want everybody to
come in and play by the rules are on
both sides of the aisle this is not a
partisan thing at all
it's you got to come to our city and
play by our rules because we got
lobbyists to take care of and we've got
a system and everybody is participating
in the system Marco Rubio actually
talked about this just the other day and
I thought it was really good he was
saying look when I came to Washington
and I didn't go to their cocktail
parties I eventually didn't get invited
to their cocktail parties and then they
started sniping at me because I wasn't
going to their cocktail parties and I
and they recognized that I wasn't
playing by their rules and he said Trump
done a 10-fold he's come in and and you
know completely double down on that and
and I think it's right I think we're
getting senators you know Ron Johnson I
think is another great senator who
doesn't play that game and he comes from
Wisconsin and and plays a different you
know tune which is I'm fighting for the
people of Wisconsin Marco Rubio I think
is doing that that we have senators that
are beginning to do that and challenge
the system and I think it's what the
people want so what's it like when Trump
Donald Trump New York businessman Donald
Trump the guy becomes president then I
assume your phone rings one day and he
says looking looking to send somebody
over to Germany is it a phone calls it
an email to someone else reach out to
you first I was that over well I so I
had been in and around to the campaign
quite a bit and so there's always a
constant conversation and there's also I
think a question of like who's loyal
right who was here before all of the
jobs were available mmm who was
committed and I think they saw that I
was very committed in in the campaign
and so the conversation to me was you
know where do you see yourself in the
administration or do you want to join
the administration and so from the
beginning I just said you know some sort
of a foreign policy role you know let's
let's discuss and and then we had that
conversation and eventually I was like I
think Germany's good fit if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell